hello there welcome to the NewsHour now
just to end the last minute the U.S
federal reserve has announced its
interest rate decision it's putting the
federal interest rate up by
0.25 points that means the overall rate
now sits at five percent let's go
straight to our correspondent Hydro
Castro she's outside the Federal Reserve
in Washington DC this was the decision I
did the Federal Reserve was widely
expected to take wasn't it
that's right these are expectations that
came after the turmoil we saw catch fire
in the banking sector in the U.S in just
the last two weeks originally it had
been predicted that today's rate hike
would be closer to half a percentage
point so seeing a quarter percentage
point is what the expectations had
tampered down to be in light of the
recent developments of course this is
all due to the two bank failures that we
saw starting on March 10th with Silicon
Valley Bank in California when it was
taken over by the federal Regulators
after failing why did it fail it could
not keep up with the withdrawals from uh
it's from its depositors because its
assets had so sharply declined in value
in part due to the continuous rate
raising of interest rates that we've
seen out of this Central Bank in the
last year of course the purpose of these
interest rate hikes is to combat this uh
inflation that remains High though we
have seen movement downwards in the last
few months so the FED bore taking this
action now raising the federal interest
rate by a quarter percentage Point
certainly a response to what we've seen
in the banking sector these last two
weeks it really is a very delicate
balancing situation that the FED finds
itself in what's going to be the
reaction do we think to this is it's
going to be is it going to be the
reaction that it's looking for
that's right we're essentially going to
be watching how the markets react they
have been trading very cautiously prior
to this decision but there have been
some expectation that there would be no
movement on the interest rate at all so
in a sense the Federal Reserve board
threading the needle there not going
right in the middle of what had been
expected prior to the bank failures and
the absolute no movement that had also
been uh predicted by some but really
what we're going to look uh forward to
as Jerome Powell the federal chair has
gives us news conference in about half
an hour's time are some pointed
questions as to if more could have been
done to prevent the bank failures not
only Silicon Valley Bank but also
Signature Bank in the days after because
the Federal Reserve had been supervising
Silicon Valley Bank in the year leading
up to this failure and there have been
multiple red flags there have been
warnings given to the bank managers
about risky uh the risky decisions of
not mitigating the risks adequately
despite those warnings apparently it did
not work to save the bank and so there
will be many questions asked of what
could have been done to prevent this
from happening and perhaps reforms in
banking regulation in the future
absolutely it will be bringing viewers
that news conference when it happens in
about half an hour as you say Heidi just
give us an idea take us back to the
broader picture here the economic crisis
at large and why the U.S is facing such
high inflation in the first place
right what we're seeing here similar
story to all over the world this is the
part of the pandemic recovery uh with
the difficulty in getting products to
the U.S the shortage in labor all of
that leading to Soaring prices we saw a
record 40-year high inflation in the U.S
in the middle of last year leading up to
last fall but we did see movement
downward in the inflation numbers as a
result of the federal reserve's
aggressive efforts to raise the interest
rate this is the ninth consecutive time
that the sport has taken this action in
just the last year however inflation
remains stubborn it's at some six
percent at this point which is already
much lower than its peak however the
target rate that the Federal Reserve
wants is two percent for a healthy
economy and we're still obviously triple
that so not only will we be hearing more
about the board's uh decision-making
process leading to this 0.25 basis
points rate hike that they now today but
we'll also be getting more of a forecast
what the chair Jerome Powell foresees
for GDP growth for how long this
inflation will stick around in the U.S
all of those answers to come when he
gives us press conference absolutely for
the moment hi Joe Castro thanks very
much for keeping up to date with all the
latest lines there from Washington Let's
cross over to Robert Scott he's a
financial analyst and a former senior
International Economist at the economic
policy Institute he joins us live from
Rockville Maryland good to have you with
us so is this the right decision by the
Federal Reserve to raise interest rates
by 0.25 percent
absolutely my fear is that it's going to
push us further in the direction of
recession and I think it's going to fall
hardest on black and brown and poor
workers who will suffer the most if we
go into a downturn
why do you think it will push us more
push the us more towards recession
well the Federal Reserve has raised
interest rates eight times in the last
year Alone by a total of more than four
percentage points adding raising rates
again will simply add more fuel to that
fire and we have to understand that the
economy is like a gigantic aircraft
carrier if you turn the wheel it takes a
long time for that vessel to turn but
once it does it's very hard to turn it
back so the FED has to be you know
aiming at a moving Target and I think
they're doing a very very bad job of
steering the ship of the economy what do
you think they should be doing then
replace me frankly I think the problem
is not excessive demand or which is what
the FED says they're worrying about it
or uh labor market tightness in fact
wage wage growth is slowing the real
problem in the economy is excessive
profit taking uh by gigantic
corporations that have gobbled up huge
segments of the economy during the covet
recession and Recovery the problem in
the word is excessive concentration and
the FED is the wrong agency to fight
that I think we need the justice
department Congress and the White House
to to address excessive concentration
and soaring corporate profits I mean of
course the FED is more focused perhaps
on the immediate term it's trying to
prevent contagion it's trying to prevent
a run on more Banks do you think that at
least is going to happen
well in fact interest rate increases
will only increase pressure on the banks
uh higher interest rates make it uh more
likely that more banks will fail as the
value of the long-term Bonds in their
portfolio continues to decline and so I
I think this is this is going to only
add fuel to the fire it's like pouring
water on a gasoline fire it will just
spread it further I think the FED should
stop raising rates and put the pressure
on Congress and the White House and in
the Justice Department to address
excessive excessive profit taking okay
increases important profits explain more
than half of the increase in inflation
over the past two years but how
difficult is it for the Federal Reserve
to balance calming inflation with
calming the problem in the banks
well I I think that the FED requires
excessive judgment and and part of the
problem is that as we know uh president
the former president Trump and Congress
regulated the banks it took him took off
some of the controls that were put in
place uh following the last Great
Recession in 2010 uh and Elizabeth
Warren had written a column in New York
Times pointing this out it was that
mistake which allowed the banks to uh be
deregulated and get away from fed
control so but the FED retains many
controls and may need to focus on
regulating the banks not uh raising
pressure on labor markets which is what
they're doing without further interest
rate increases okay Robert Scott great
to speak to you thanks very much for
joining us to explain a little bit more
on this breaking news at the Federal
Reserve in the U.S has just raised
interest rates by 0.25 percent